what I want to do is think about whether
this expression right over here would
evaluate the same way whether or not we
had parentheses so to think about that
let's first think about how it would
evaluate if we have the parentheses so
if we add the parentheses we want to do
whatever in the parentheses first and so
here we have 8 minus 3 which is equal to
5 so this simplifies to 5 times 5 times
8 minus 3 and now we want to do the
multiplication before we do subtraction
this goes back to order of operations
you do your multiplication and division
first well you do your parentheses first
then if you have multiplication division
and addition and subtraction all in a
row you want to do your multiplication
and your division first so here we're
going to multiply 5 times 8 to get 40
and then we're going to subtract 3 to
get 37 now let's think about what this
will do it about this what this would
evaluate to if we did not have the
parentheses so it would be 8 minus 3
times 8 minus 3 so we just have to
remind ourselves about the order of
operations the convention is is to do
your multiplication first so you're
actually going to multiply the 3 times
the 8 before you subtract it from this 8
and then before you subtract this 3 so
we took away the parentheses but the
order of operations say hey do this
multiplication first we could even put a
parenthesis here to emphasize that so
this will become 8 minus 8 minus 24 so
let me write this way 8 minus 24 minus 3
8 minus 24 minus 3 now 8 minus 24 is
negative 16 you subtract a negative
another 3 you're going to get 2 negative
19 so clearly clearly you get very very
different values depending on whether or
not you have parentheses